liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die kogit
19 pandemie hat sich in deutschland in
den vergangenen wochen weiter verschärft
insbesondere nimmt die zahl der
infektionen mit der besonderen
ansteckenden omikron variante drastisch
zu
vor diesem hintergrund haben sich die
fraktionen mehrheitlich auf verstärkte
schutzmaßnahmen zur eindämmung der
verbreitung des kroner virus im
deutschen bundestag verständigt
dementsprechend habe ich auch meine
allgemeinverfügung zu corona
schutzmaßnahmen im deutschen bundestag
mit wirkung zum heutigen tage geändert
für das plenum bedeutet dies folgendes
für den zutritt zur parlamentssitzung
soll fortan eine 2d plus regeln gelten
zudem soll die bestehende masten pflicht
dadurch verschärft werden dass im
plenarsaal eine ffp zwei maske getragen
werden muss die zweite die 2g regel plus
bedeutet dass zutritt zum plenarsaal in
der unteren ebene ausschließlich
diejenigen personen erhalten die
vollständig gegen das saas kopf 2 virus
geimpft oder von einer corona erkrankung
genesen sind und das ist das plus 2 das
ist das plus der zwei plus regel die
darüber hinaus negativ getestet oder
gemustert sind also eine
auffrischungsimpfung erhalten haben
dieser zweig plus status ist nach
maßgabe der allgemeinverfügung als
zutrittsberechtigung zur unteren ebenen
des plenarsaals uns zur west und
abgeordneten lobby
nachzuweisen diejenigen abgeordneten die
zwar weder geimpft noch gelesen aber
negativ getestet sind können unter
wahrung des abstands gebots auf den
tribünen platz nehmen und von dort aus
an der sitzung teilnehmen und zwar wie
gewohnt auch mit redebeiträgen
die eingangs erwähnte verschärfte masken
pflicht bezieht sich allein auf die
qualität der zu tragenden maske anstelle
von medizinischen masken zu denen auch
op masken gehören dürfen im lena sei
nunmehr nur noch ffb zwei masken
getragen werden diese ffb zwei massen
pflicht gilt wie zuvor auch am platz und
lässt aus nahm allein für die
amtierenden präsidentinnen und
präsidenten sowie für die rednerinnen
und redner am redepult und an den saal
mikrofon zu
bitte beachten sie auch die ausnahmen
und die befreiung aus medizinischen
gründen die die allgemeinverfügung in
bezug auf die 2g plus regeln und die
masken pflicht vorsieht
bevor wir jetzt zur abstimmung kommen
wird die fraktion der afd das wort zur
geschäftsordnung
ergreifen er dr baumann
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
der bundeskanzler sagt bei der
bekämpfung des kroner virus darf es
keine roten linien geben ich sage ihnen
in einer freiheitlichen demokratie muss
es rote linien geben
gerade hier im deutschen bundestag
werden sie heute einmal mehr
überschritten eine völlig neue
überzogene kroner verordnung greift tief
in das freie mandat der parlamentarier
ein selbst abgeordnete die sich hier
offiziell im bundestag direkt vor dieser
sitzung haben testen lassen und den
einwandfrei bestätigt bestätigt wurde
dass sie kein corona haben selbst diesen
abgeordneten wird jetzt der zutritt ins
plenum verweigert sie dürfen hier nicht
sitzen sie dürfen an diesem pult nicht
reden sie dürfen also ihre
verfassungsmäßige rechte nicht ausüben
das kann nicht sein das darf nicht sein
das kann nicht so bleiben meine damen
und herren
abgeordnete müssen jetzt über den klaren
negativ test hinaus zusätzlich noch
nachweise erbringen über doppelte
impfungen oder genesung wozu das
führende deutsche verfassungsrechtler
hat das sofort alarmiert ich zitiere nur
den lehrstuhlinhaber für öffentliches
recht der universität oldenburg
professor boehme neßler warnte gestern
mit blick auf den bundestag sofort
wörtlich
getesteten auf die tribüne zu verbannen
ist nicht erforderlich ist
unverhältnismäßig und ist damit
verfassungswidrig
deutlicher kann man es doch gar nicht
sagen meine damen und herren
sie schieben also nachweislich gesunde
auf die besuchertribüne ganz dort oben
wo sie von anderen abgeordneten nicht
gesehen werden sie halten also praktisch
saal verbot werden von der gemeinschaft
alle abgeordneten abgetrennt und so
schikaniert mit ihrer krone politik
spalten sie nicht nur die gesellschaft
zu spalten auch dieses parlament meine
damen und herren
denn gleichzeitig dürfen andere
abgeordnete hier im plenum völlig
ungetestet sitzen nur wegen einer
sogenannten booster impfung dabei weist
der mittlerweile jeder dass selbst
dreifach geimpfte das virus übertragen
können niemand weiß wie viel hier vorne
in wirklichkeit infiziert sind
die einzig vernünftige regel wäre
deshalb alle zu testen das aber tun sie
nicht sie setzten sich damit den
erkenntnissen der wissenschaft entgegen
überdies wegen sie jetzt auch noch alle
abgeordneten trotz abstand halten statt
normaler op masken jetzt die dicke ffp
zwei maske zu tragen immer und überall
den ganzen tag während stunden langes
tragen
der schwerter atmen stört die
konzentration selbst professor wieder
präsident des robert koch-instituts
warnt diese masken seien für den alltag
nicht zu gebrauchen all diese
einschränkungen gefährden die arbeit der
abgeordneten spalten das parlament und
sie sind auch noch sinnlos wie sagt
bereits der zitierte staatsrechtler
wörtlich verfassungsmäßige rechte durch
sinnlose maßnahmen einzuschränken
erlaubt die verfassung auf gar keinen
fall halten sie sich daran meine damen
und herren
als nächste rednerin für die spd
fraktion katja mast
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
kolleginnen und kollegen meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren heute morgen
die neuesten
infektionszahlen
1430 die höchsten infektionszahlen seit
beginn der pandemie in berlin
9000 neue infektionen und deshalb bin
ich froh dass die
bundestagspräsidentin die initiative
ergriffen hat die allgemeinverfügung zu
verändern es ist absolut geboten und es
ist richtig dass wir die notwendigen
maßnahmen zum schutz von uns allen in
die wege leiten
grundsätzlich will ich aber auch sagen
dass die rechte der abgeordneten die
ausübung des freien mandats überhaupt
nicht in gefahr sind trotz der schon
geltenden geänderten allgemeinverfügung
führen wir hier diese freie und offene
debatte das ist ein beleg dafür
und im gegenteil mit dieser
allgemeinverfügung
stärken wir die funktionsfähigkeit des
deutschen bundestags und
gewährleisten damit dass auch wichtige
entscheidungen in zukunft weiterhin hier
getroffen werden können
und weil es nicht nur um die
mandatsträgerinnen und mandatsträger
sondern auch die mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter im deutschen bundestag in
den abgeordnetenbüros in der verwaltung
aber auch hier vor mir und hierbei den
saal dienerin und saaldiener geht es
geht auch um den schutz der
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter hier
immer aus da haben wir eine besondere
verantwortung dafür und
was regelt regeln wir wir führen eine
ffp zwei masken pflicht ein die gilt in
berlin ab samstag in allen bereichen wir
machen nichts anderes als das was die
menschen draußen im land auch tun ihren
im deutschen bundestag und 2g plus in
plenarsitzungen und
ausschusssitzungen und veranstaltungen
des bundestags bei jedem restaurant
besuchte zweige plus und wir tun ihres
wertes im deutschen bundestag nicht
notwendig
es geht hier darum dass wir den schutz
der menschen im deutschen bundestag
genau so leben die menschen müssen das
auch tun wir erwarten es von ihnen jeden
tag und deshalb ist es richtig dass wir
das so machen und auch ihre ablehnung im
prinzip man ja heute auch ob es sehr gut
es gibt hier vier fraktionen die sagen
wir halten abstand auch im plenarsaal
sie finden dass es nicht notwendig auch
das zeigt ihre fünf entschuldigung schön
fraktion im deutschen bundestag
zeigen dass und sie wollen einfach den
menschen sand in die augen streuen und
sagen wir können diese pandemie nicht in
den griff bekommen durch unser volk nur
das gegenteil ist der fall das verhalten
von jedem einzelnen von jeder einzelnen
hat auswirkungen für die gesundheit in
diesem land und deshalb ist es richtig
was die parlamentspräsidentin in die
wege geleitet hat vielen dank für diese
änderungen der allgemeinen sind
nächster redner für die cdu csu fraktion
ist er frei
kaiser
erste frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen es ist in der tat die frage
zu stellen worüber reden wir eigentlich
über eine verschärfte masken pflicht und
über 2g hier im plenum des deutschen
bundestages und ich will das für unsere
fraktion ganz klar sagen wir halten das
für eine richtige und für eine
notwendige entscheidung denn es ist doch
wirklich darauf hinzuweisen in welchem
umfeld bewegen wir uns es sind nicht nur
erstmals mehr als 80.000 neue
infektionen am heutigen tag wir haben
ein infektionsgeschehen das etwa 130
prozent über dem des vorjahreszeitraums
liegt und wir haben die situation dass
wir hier in berlin mitte eine inzidenz
von neun
176,2 haben und deswegen muss man sich
doch auf fragen welches bild wir als
parlament in der öffentlichkeit abgeben
wir verlangen von den menschen
einschränkungen in form von
schutzmaßnahmen und mehr als abgeordnete
wären nicht bereit diese maßnahmen auch
für uns gelten zu lassen das ist nicht
akzeptabel dass es keine führung von
vorne und deswegen ist es wichtig was in
der allgemeinverfügung der präsidentin
drin steht
es sind nicht nur die menschen die
meinen ich will das auch an die kollegen
sagen von jedem schulkind in deutschland
erwarten wir dass es sich testen lässt
und sie und sie vergessen hier
krokodilstränen und schwadronieren über
die einschränkungen die damit verbunden
sind das ist nicht akzeptabel und
deswegen machen wir es so wie die frau
präsidentin vorgeschlagen hat und es
geht in der tat um zwei dinge es geht
zum einen darum dass wir einen beitrag
zum übergeordneten ziel dieser pandemie
bekämpfung leisten nämlich eine
überlastung des gesundheitswesens zu
verhindern und es geht auch darum dass
wir die funktionsfähigkeit des deutschen
bundestages aufrechterhalten weil wir
dafür sorgen müssen dass wir auch in
zukunft in der lage sind hier im
bundestag die notwendigen beschlüsse für
die zukunft unseres landes zu treffen
und deswegen verehrte frau präsidentin
bin ich ihnen und sind wir uns sind wir
ihnen als unions fraktion ausdrücklich
dankbar dafür dass sie hier das heft des
handelns in die hand genommen haben dass
sie die notwendigen maßnahmen getroffen
haben dass sie führung gezeigt haben
eine führung liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wie wir sie uns auch von der
bundesregierung und dem bundeskanzler
erwarten würden führung in schwieriger
zeit führung in einer der größten krisen
unseres landes diese führung erwarten
wir und deswegen verehrter herr schulz
nehmen sie sich ein beispiel an unserer
parlamentspräsidentin herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
weitere wortmeldung zur geschäftsordnung
liegen mir nicht vor wir kommen damit
nun zur abstimmung über die eben
erläuterte zweig plus regel sowie über
die verschärfte masken pflicht im
plenarsaal als teil unserer
parlamentarischen ordnung
wer stimmt dafür
dass in die fraktion die linke spd
bündnis 90 die grünen fdp cdu csu
fraktion wer stimmt dagegen das ist die
fdp fraktion gibt es enthaltungen
das sehe ich nicht damit sind die neuen
regeln als teil unserer
parlamentarischen ordnung beschlossen